ciara she's been working so hard getting
to her body after baby back
she has been dropping 50 pounds yes five
months after giving birth to her
daughter Sienna and only our Lord Siva
found out how she did it on the set of
Firoz news videos sure people tell you
this all time but you look amazing what
is the most important thing you do just
for your physical wellness for your body
every day oh my gosh tons of water water
is key and I think honestly just
listening to your body I really like
talk to my son like brain I'm gonna eat
those fries right now brownie ice cream
I hear you I'm gonna eat you tomorrow
and in Sierra's guide to living your
best life you also have to embrace your
flaws even something so real is having
stretch marks on my back on both sides I
look at those babies and I'm like it's
all worth it like this is beautiful
he was exclusive on the set of the 33
year old Grammy winners new music video
thinking about you
Sierra says her nearly two-year-old
daughter Sienna is already showing signs
of being a performer I was rehearsing I
jumped to the bed that jump around like
singing with the hairbrush and all this
fun stuff and she's watching me and
she's like mimicking like she's loving
to dance guys have cute kids do you
think about expanding any adopting
anything like that I do think about it
and I do want to do it again but I'm
having fun dancing right now with the
little flat tummy it's all I need to
look like that is a glass of water let's
get a big I might bring Matt Galland new
house of beauty smarts drop may 10
[Music]